what I want you to know is a couple of
things last night for starters
do you notice if you look right at the
top it's quite hard to see ours even a
little clue why at the top in tiny great
numbers you can see those three digit
numbers one of those those are degrees
or longitude
right because we're going we're going
east west at the moment so 100m degrees
so 65 you remember they're every 15
degrees because why why because each one
represents an hour which is why beneath
the longitude measurements it says plus
10 plus 11 that means it's 10 out of the
head of and 11 out of the head all and
12 hours ahead or can anyone guess is
the Greenwich Mean Time which is of the
prime rib so just go back to these guys
right B would be GMT plus 1 and a would
be GMT plus 2 because question I think
you to see a GMT are just different
acronyms missing people yeah on
universal something anyway goes up it up
what I'm most interested in is can you
see here's 180 right you can come from
the east or from the weather you get to
the same spot but then really quickly
you notice the International Day liner
which is in black does not always follow
the 180 degree line so I'm going to say
sometimes watch how sometimes it is you
can see this spot up here which is up in
the Arctic Circle this is up at the
North Pole
yeah there's up in the fall so here up
in the Arctic Circle you can see the
Arctic Ocean there there's nothing much
interesting happening so therefore
you're right on the 1 to 3 degree line
but as soon as you start to approach
land it weighs around and pretty sure
that's what this is this Alaska
that's what this resistance sorry this
is yeah wait let's Siberia support so
really right here
right so you can see it bends around in
fact it goes pretty far away from that
hundred edges
why is that what I try and choose the
voice trading fine so what they're doing
is they're trying to avoid these two
different sides of a line being within
egg country because on either side
remember as usually so there you go
right so further you go you're all
marching forward in time you're marching
forward in time so maybe 12:00 dude and
1 p.m. 2 p.m. 3 p.m. and so on right but
eventually you come back to where you
started and it's not like you can just
keep on going in this before word in
time so therefore when you cross
backwards and forwards you lose a day
and you lose a day so all the way
forward you're plus plus plus plus plus
an hour until you get back and then you
lose there you have to subtract 24
because you're back where you started
right now that changes across the slides
you can see in ways around Russia it
comes back you can see it keeps on going
around because they do the string of
islands in here that is US territory it
returns it likes another journey degrees
but it doesn't stay there how long so
here's the Pacific ok it's hard to see
because of all of the colors but I want
to point out if you go back to the top
the colors represent different time
zones ok so the sizes don't exactly fit
along the brilliance because of
countries b1 things are not being
different so yeah it's just when we have
a look at here again follow that black
line so you can see here it is right
remember I said as you cross if you keep
on going east like my imaginary journey
was over there you keep on adding adding
adding hours but once you cross that
line you have to take away all those
hours that you just added on ok if
you're traveling direction you have to
add time right because if I was
traveling to the west
you're going backwards in time backwards
the time
the tile until you would background
you've got back to it back because
you'll be back where you started but
have a look taters alone down here and
then suddenly it goes each it goes a big
time and it whips around here it is we
sort of have a shake and then it comes
around and the whole edge of islands
just cut straight through and then it
eventually returns back 280° island
right so once upon time in fact there
was about twenty years ago which is the
scheme of things not that long ago
oh this line actually went straight down
and passed through Fiji
so can you see where a hundred eighty
degrees sort of where is he on right
in fact that have you come back to
underneath here it is so you can see
Fiji is right on this 108 degrees okay
but it doesn't go there anymore so about
25 22 23 years ago you can look it up
these guys in here
Kiribati they said yet we don't like the
line going down like this we don't like
the line cutting right through here
through here and you can see why the
Kiribati Islands he are spread out
really far yes you've got some here and
here and here these are all part of
Kiribati
so they didn't want their own territory
being in two different days at the same
time it was just missing with their
brains
so therefore have a look at the line I
was there on the right hand side but
very quick to dental vein I don't want
to guess what the Line Islands are there
doctor it looks like there days after
the International Dateline right but
coincidentally it gives you now and have
a look a lot of you buying in fact the
Line Islands are named after the equator
line right so the equator line goes
pretty much baby through them which is
what sailors need Berlin island after
and then 1997 I think it was the
government to your body said actually
we're also going to declare us ourselves
all on this side of the International
Dateline is that weird shape of it okay
so honestly then
comes back to you and you can see it
waves around one last time before it
actually returns to the 180 degrees
there it is okay you talking about quick
here or here yeah so this is visual
energy this is hydrogen a degrees this
is a dreary and digit not because of
these guys these money sir you don't
need you'll never have to be like tested
or like ah which I wonder which one's
out but while I'm trying to get across
to you is essentially time is about
these meridians except for a few
oddities of history where we decided to
do things differently for whatever
reason economical business historical we
think okay so by now you've got your
computer there now so what I want you to
do is come up a look at excise Kenji
let's have a look at using this dollars
has not that complicated in aggression
like this so I'm going to robot my blue
so the basic value remember how many
degrees result in an hour of 23 degrees
15 degrees this degrees longitude which
means that every degree of longitude is
how much time different an hour is 60
minutes right so if I divide both sides
by 50 then this will result in four
minutes over on the other side and one
degree or negative on the right hand
side so have a look simple question it
says by the difference in local time
finally these calculators for this time
between two places with a longer two
different off whatever okay so let's do
the first couple
a thirty degrees of difference right
every degree gives you four minutes so
this is going to be equal to how many
minutes 120 minutes we generally want
everything because of the scalar work
you we generally want to be in hours so
that throughout let's get over to Part C
if you've got 85 degrees difference
there's a bit more an awkward number so
you go ahead every degree is 4 minutes
so you multiply by 4 you get 300 point
minutes now you could go ahead and do
the thinking yourself to do the
conversion but there's an easier way
sorry Holly is just going to pitch this
you talk during your head with a right
now a new era now you can't think this
through a dear sixties it'll like on a
food but in case this is some weird
rendered model right here's an easy way
to do it 340 go ahead and type to reason
40 how many visits are there in an hour
60 so if you want to divide sorry if you
want to convert this into hours just go
ahead and divide by 60 okay now what is
going to hide you as a decimal because
it's a calculator works in decimals but
our calculators can do conversions for
time for imperial right which button are
we going to need it's the degrees
minutes and seconds under the right so
my calculator display or Holly's checker
display currently says five point six
six six six etc so if I keep degrees
minutes seconds it's going to be five
hours and forty minutes which makes
sense because if you add another 20
minutes to the Internet six hours which
is 300 C you do it okay so you can also
be answered in Reverse
this is if you're given the angle
difference between magnitude if you're
given the time difference that you can
also work out what have these degrees
apart should matrix